[Musique]
depuis le collège au lycée on nous
demande qu'est ce qu'on aimerait faire
plus tard dans la vie
moi mon rêve c'était de devenir
entrepreneur
j'ai toujours été fasciné par les
entrepreneurs ces personnes incroyables
qui partent souvent de rien créer leur
boîte crime start-up arrive à construire
des empires et à faire des choses
incroyables qui change radicalement la
vie des gens ça m'a toujours inspiré et
je me suis toujours dit qu'un jour moi
aussi je ferai partie de ces personnes
alors j'ai dû apprendre à entreprendre
je fais dans une école j'ai appris le
marketing la coume le la communication
la gestion de projet la gestion d'une
entreprise
et tout ça ça m'a vraiment passionné
j'avais trouvé ma voie j'ai aussi durant
toute cette période la rencontre et un
tas d'entrepreneurs j'ai discuté avec
eux j'ai essayé de comprendre leur vie
et leur passé comment il avait réussi
justement à passer ces étapes là comment
il avait réussi à se lancer et la chose
qu'on a enseigné à ce moment là c'était
que l'entrepreneuriat ça se passe par
des étapes l'étape numéro un qui est
commune à tous les entrepreneurs c'est
la phase de l'idée c'est ce moment à peu
agréable vous avez une nouvelle idée
tiens j'aimerais bien lancé ma boîte
tiens j'ai une idée j'ai peut-être créer
une start up c'est un moment qui est
hyper agréable
le problème avec les idées c'est que
tant que vous les rendez pas réel bah
vous n'êtes pas vraiment entrepreneurs
et moi c'est un peu mon problème j'avais
tout le temps un tas d'idées
j'avais envie de faire plein de choses
mais j'avais rien j'arrivais jamais à
rendre réel toutes ces idées que j'avais
dans ma tête il ya deux ans j'étais avec
des amis un apéro chez moi
tranquillement le type d'apéro qu'on
connaît tous un on parle de tout de rien
de la pluie du beau temps on a compris
que ça généralement à quelques
bouteilles de vin et puis là on est en
train de discuter des prochaines soirées
avec mes amis qu'on allait pouvoir faire
et on trouvait qu'il y avait un problème
on trouvait que les soirées elles se
ressembler
tout le temps c'était tout le temps les
mêmes dj c'est tout le temps une même
musique
c'était souvent les mêmes thèmes c'est
souvent fait les mêmes choses qui
revenait et ça manque énormément d'un
certain renouveau
et puis on a commencé un peu à
brainstorm et on a commencé un peu à
s'imaginer nous qu'est ce qu'on ferait
demain si on était organisateur de
soirées et puis bon on commence à
trouver un thème à notre futur soir et
on s'y tient
si on faisait un thème sur la casa des
papes elle vous savez la série netflix
lac était à la mode on la regardait tout
son soutien ça pourrait être sympa
d'utiliser ce terme est de faire une
soirée comme ça et puis tiens si c'était
nous les dj qu'on passait derrière des
platines et puis bon pour être déguisé
certains en braqueur d'autres en
policier on pourrait même décoré le lieu
la salle la salle de notre événement on
pourrait la transformer une sorte de
banque
maître de la décoration de partout des
billets de banque on continue encore à
imaginer cette soirée la soirée un peu
de nos rêves 11e' même tiens ce serait
super sympa d'organiser des jeux des
animations
enfin on rajoute à un truc pour que les
gens puissent vraiment s'amuser à notre
soirée
et puis voilà l'apéro se termine
l'idée reste dans un coin quelques jours
plus tard je suis en ville
je m'assois un bar et l'a instantanément
je me remémore ses discussions avec mes
potes je me remémore ce tout ce qu'on
avait imaginé je me dis tiens ça
pourrait faire un bon endroit ici pour
une soirée
je vois directement le serveur le gérant
du bar et je leur pose quelques
questions
je leur évoque notre conseil je leur
présente un peu nos idées et je leur
demande s'il serait possible d'organiser
ça dans leur établissement
et puis là ma grande surprise le gérant
me dis bah écoutez dans trois mois on a
une date le 13 juillet vous pouvez la
faire là votre soirée du coup moi et
hyper surpris il super content je
retourne chez moi et je décide d'avertir
mes potes sur 10 gigas vous vous
rappelez le truc qu'on a parlé là et
quelques jours notre fameuse soirée etc
vous savez quoi j'ai une date et j'ai un
lieu donc on décide de se retrouver à la
maison en quelques jours après puis on
dit on va quand même essayer de cadrer
et d'organiser tout ça de manière un peu
plus sérieusement quand même
et du coup on commence à poser un peu
les grandes lignes du projet une sorte
de rétro planning on commence un peu à
budgétiser tout ça mais rapidement on se
rend compte qu'on n'y est pas du tout on
est loin d'y être parce que ben on n'a
pas les compétences
on n'est pas graphiste on est incapable
de faire une affiche on pourrait
éventuellement faire un événement
facebook mais on sait pas gérer un
projet on n'a jamais fait ça c'est
vraiment nouveau pour nous de là on se
rend compte que on a besoin d'une équipe
on a besoin s'entourer de compétences
qu'est ce qu'on fait eh ben on parle de
ce projet à nos proches à nos
connaissances à nos amis et puis à
quelques-uns de nos amis qui trouve le
concept sympa et qu'ils disent tiens on
pourrait peut-être vous donner un coup
de main est ce qu'on peut vous rejoindre
donc on a une personne de personnes
trois personnes qui nous rejoignent et
finalement on se retrouve avec une
équipe de six personnes plutôt
pluridisciplinaire avec chacun on va
dire son domaine de compétence qui
allait apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
donc on se réunit on cadre un peu plus
ce projet on met en place un budget on
est en place à rétro planning mais là
globalement on était un peu dans une
situation un peu d'une petite entreprise
ou une petite start up une jeune équipe
qui commence et qui a une idée et comme
les start up ou comme les petites
entreprises qui commencent on avait un
gros problème
on avait un gros problème c'est qu'on
n'avait même pas d'argent pour financer
le démarrage de notre soirée pays la
décoration etc
on n'avait pas d'argent mais bon on
avait des idées est l'une des idées
qu'on a eu on saisit bah tiens et si on
essayait d'aller convaincre un sponsor
du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait on envoie
des mails on envoie des messages on
prépare un beau dossier de présentation
et par chance un sponsor nous dit ok les
gars prenons rendez vous ai même parlé
de votre truc
alors nous bat on prépare notre rendez
vous on avait notre dossier
mais je dois vous dire qu'on avait
extrêmement peur on avait peur d'être
ridicule parce que ben on n'était pas
une agence d'événementiel
on n'avait pas d'expérience dans le
domaine on savait globalement pas trop
ce qu'on faisait on était plutôt
effrayer mais bon on décide quand même
d'y aller parce qu'on avait une équipe
et on avait des idées
donc du coup on va rendez vous on lui
expose le projet et là surprise aussi le
sponsor nous fait confiance
le sponsor nous dit les gars voici votre
budget vous pouvez la faire votre soirée
donc l'appareil je retourne à la maison
je préviens mes potes jeudi écoutez on a
le budget on est une équipe on a une
date on a un lieu finalement on va la
faire cette soirée donc là on commence à
travailler
on travaille on avance les trucs
globalement ça se passe plutôt bien
mais dans l'équation il manquait un truc
on avait globalement tous mais il nous
manquait une chose qui était hyper
importante
il fallait qu'il y ait des gens qui
viennent à notre soirée parce que là on
lançait tous les trucs mi6 avait
personne
on allait se retrouver avec des dettes
ou avec des dépenses qu'on n'est pas
prévu du coup on dit bah ça serait
génial d'avoir un partenaire média ou
presse avec nous alors pareil on envoie
nos dossiers on essaie de contacter
quelques médias locaux les radios etc et
on a une radio qui veut bien nous
rencontrer donc on y va on explose de
projets notre concept et ils sont hyper
emballé mais par contre on avait un
sacré problème
on avait un problème parce que ba cette
même radio
elle avait prévu également d'organiser
une grosse soirée avec des déguisements
de la décoration un pm assez proche du
nôtre d'ailleurs mais eux par contre il
faisait ça dans la plus grosse boîte de
nuit de tahiti et en plus il faisait
venir un dj de france le pire dans tout
ça c'est que leur soirée à eux
elle tombait pile poil le même sort que
notre soirée alors je peux vous dire on
est rentrés à la maison et on s'est posé
un tas de questions
on n'est pas du tout confiance en nous
on se dit mais on va se faire exploser
quoi il y aura personne un autre truc
même nom est presque envie d'aller leur
sauveur donc c'était un peu chaud et
finalement si on se réunit avec l'équipe
on parle et on dit bon on va quand même
le faire on va quand même y aller on va
pas s'arrêter là
et du coup on y va mais on y va mais on
avait peur on avait peur d'avoir
personne rétorque pas rentrer dans nos
frais mais on s'est dit que c'était pas
grave et que on avait tellement peur de
se rater bah on allait mobiliser
l'ensemble de nos potes et de toutes nos
connaissances on allait tout faire pour
vendre l'intégralité des billets avant
que la soirée ait lieu
et du coup c'est ce qu'on a fait on a
lancé la communication on a lancé la
billetterie
on en a parlé à tous nos potes c'était
limite les gars si vous devez vendre des
billets même à votre grand mère vendait
des billets d'y aller et puis finalement
bas les billets commencent à partir
puis ils partent plutôt bien même ils
partent même carrément bien les billets
ils partent tellement bien qu'en
l'espace de dix jours on avait vendu
l'ensemble des places pour notre
événement
globalement le baril est aigri mais on
n'allait pas perdre d'argent
on allait s'en sortir on n'avait plus
peur en tout cas de se rater là dessus
mais du coup on avait une nouvelle peur
qui est arrivé et cette peur là bas ont
saisi mais maintenant qu'il aura 300
personnes à notre événement
on n'a pas le droit de se rater on n'a
pas le droit de les décevoir les mêmes
nous ont commencé à stresser
est ce qu'on aura la capacité de gérer
tout ça est-ce que globalement on va
réussir à le revendre la soirée de nos
rêves
alors du coup les deux dernières
semaines qui ont suivi on a travaillé
énormément
on s'est organisé on s'est structuré on
a mis fin aux débats inutiles qu'on
pouvait avoir des fois au sein de
l'équipe parce que ce qui compte est
juste était de réussir cet événement est
d'être prêt le jour j
les journées sont passé tellement vite
on a assez peu dormi on a travaillé une
nuitée jours du week-end entier et
finalement on y est c'est le jour j
c'est le grand jour
on arrive sur le lieu de l'événement on
commence à installer la scène
on commence à installer la décoration
quelques bénévoles viennent nous aider
donner un coup de main donc on les
oriente et c est globalement comme tout
était réglé comme du papier à musique
tout se passe plutôt bien dans trois
heures on va ouvrir les portes et on va
pouvoir enfin faire notre soleil ça
commençait à devenir réel et puis là la
police débarque
la police débarque et nous demandent une
autorisation de la mairie pour installer
la scène sur l'espace public comme on
était des bons amateurs on n'aime pas
son autorisation
et là je peux vous dire c'est le drame
vous n'avez qu'une envie c'est prendre
un avion et partir pourquoi pas parce
qu'on se dit mais si jamais on annule la
soirée v du nom pourra jamais rembourser
les gens et puis ben on n'était pas
connu mon risque d'être fortement connus
comme les mecs qui font plus gros fail
de tahiti quoi enfin là pendant deux
trois minutes on était vraiment pas bien
quoi c'était la merde on n'était pas
beau à voir
et puis finalement on arrive à trouver
une solution
on se dit que si la scène on la met à
l'intérieur du bar bondues plus sur
l'espace public et donc on peut la faire
nôtre soirée donc c'est ce qu'on a fait
et là je peux vous dire on n'a pas
réfléchi
on a tout démonté on a tous remonter
rapidement chacun savait ce qu'il avait
à faire et on a pris un peu de retard
mais finalement on a réussi à ouvrir et
à faire d'autres soirées est la sienne
on y était c'est réel les gens
commencent à arriver
les gens commencent à s'amuser commence
à boire découle où il commence à danser
à chanter et même nous tout le stress
qu'on avait accumulé deux semaines après
semaines jusqu'au moment fatidique va
finalement le stress ils commencent à
partir
il commence à partir on commence même à
prendre plaisir à notre soirée la
dernière heure c'est carrément
l'apothéose
il ya toute l'équipe qui est sur scène
on chante on danse on s'amuse on rigole
on rigole avec le public on passe un
moment extraordinaire
humainement émotionnellement on vit un
moment de partage avec le public on a
l'impression d'être en communion avec
son public
et on termine notre soirée le public
nous applaudit nous remercie pour cette
soirée extraordinaire qu'on installé et
on avait globalement l'impression d'être
un peu les stars de la soirée et je peux
vous dire là il y avait un moment de
bonheur qui était incommensurable
finalement on a tout démonté on est
rentrés chez nous on a enfin pu se
reposer après ces semaines de travail
éreintante et stressante et puis ça nous
a permis de prendre un peu de recul
quelques jours après on devait tirer le
bilan de cette soirée et se réunir une
nouvelle fois tous ensemble est tiré
et bilan qu'on a un peu tous fait de cet
événement
ses co organisé une soirée s'écoule sur
le papier mais c'est globalement 99%
dans merde pour juste 1% de bonheur et
finalement l'aventuré est en train de se
terminer et on s'est posé la question de
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
continue et ce qu'on arrête
notre avis on a fait quoi on va
continuer on a continué parce qu'en fait
le 1 % de bonheur qu'on a pu vivre à ce
moment là les remerciements des gens
les sourires l'aventuré également de
l'équipe ensemble toutes les épreuves
qu'on a dû passer et que les gens n'ont
pas forcément vu de l'autre côté de la
barrière
à tous ces moments là il s'était
tellement fort humainement c'était
tellement fort émotionnellement qu on
s'est dit on ne peut pas s'arrêter là on
est obligé de continuer et du coup on a
continué on a refait d'autres soirées on
sait également structuré on a monté une
association
on a déposé des statuts on établit des
rôles président trésorier etc
on a mis en place une stratégie avec des
événements récurrents régulier et c est
finalement pendant toute cette année là
on appris énormément de choses on appris
énormément de choses moi l'une des
choses que j'ai retenu de toute cette
histoire l'a déjà la première chose
c'était si demain je devais entreprendre
un projet si jamais demain je devais
entreprendre et l'esc raymond
entreprises dans un autre secteur une
autre activité
si je décide d'être entrepreneur je dois
m'attendre à avoir des problèmes sur mon
chemin et de toute façon les problèmes
il y en aura tout le temps et vous êtes
obligé de faire avec
vous devez votre boulot entre
entrepreneurs c'est notamment de savoir
résoudre ces problèmes et si vous
arrivez à résoudre des problèmes et bien
vous allez pouvoir créer de la valeur
vous allez pouvoir changer la vie des
gens est le meilleur moyen de créer de
la valeur c'est de résoudre des
problèmes
la deuxième chose que j'ai retenu dans
tout ça c'est que globalement la peur
elle est toujours présente aussi elle
disparaît jamais mais en fait le
simplement de faire et de recommencer
encore et encore on développe une sorte
d'immunité face à la peur
c'est à dire qu'elle reste toujours là
mais on arrive à faire avec on arrive à
avancer et plus vous en faites
et plus les immunités va être puissante
elle va être forte enfin cette histoire
qu'est ce qu'elle m'a fait rappeler elle
m'a rappelé tout ce que les
entrepreneurs que j'ai pu rencontrer
auparavant m'avait dit m'avait dit alan
l'entrepreneuriat ça se passe par des
étapes est le plus dur à faire c'est
d'enchaîner les étapes à étapes sans
avoir peur et sans se poser de questions
en fait au final la seule peur qu'on
devrait garder nous demain ou toute
personne qui aimerait entreprendre c'est
simplement la peur d'avoir des regrets
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]